Heath is with us in Kansas hi Keith
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
thanks for taking my call Dave sure
what's up my wife and I are working on
baby step two just recently started we
don't have too much debt but the one
thing that's bothering me is I had a
student loan back in 1986 it was only
for $2,000 but I don't believe I ever
paid any money on it
every once in a while I get a letter in
the mail from always a different
collection agency on this and they say
that you know it's a loose owed backed
by the US government their education
whatever but it's it's never showing up
on my credit report or anywhere else all
I get is you know an occasional notice
from a debt collector generally to check
on if this debt is still valid is it
something that I need to still worry
about if it is unpaid it is still valid
because there's not a statute of
limitations on student loans federally
insured student loans survive forever
until they're paid and so you know you
could check with the Department of
Education and see if they have a
database search process and yeah I would
pull a copy of all three of your credit
bureaus and see if it shows up on any of
them and of course if you don't find any
of that then the next time you do get a
letter then engage with those people and
dig in and get the try to get some
detailed information and an audit on the
account rather than just the general
thing of you always some money and
here's how much I want to know how you
arrived at that figure because I suspect
it's going to be pretty substantial I
mean that's a lot of interest here we're
talking about from the 80s to now and
penalties and other things that you
probably have to negotiate through
you're not going to negotiate through
the principal or the interest though